I don't know why one of our producers
typed her name into eBay today and this
came up and I just want to ask
[Applause]
it's thought you might want to watch you
might want to buy that what's what's the
bidding it right now we're gonna close
it out you're gonna buy it
very good okay there's six available
[Laughter]
oh my god Thank You Conan it's what I do
you're such a good chemistry between you
and Robert Downey jr. in the film and
this is probably annoying to a
screenwriter but it feels to me there
are lines that are were you guys are so
in sync that it feels almost improvised
well you know we did there was a lot of
that in the movie some of it gets into
the film you know and having Shane black
who directed it and wrote it co-wrote it
with Drew Pearce
they weren't precious with it you know
what I mean so we they let it breathe
well you can't what are you gonna do
with Robert you can't really stop him
yeah the mind is so he just goes and you
really feel like you have to you know
keep up it's like playing speed tennis
or something right so he's so there's
there's a lot that he was on speed
what's with you I don't know with these
people I you know I've tried to reason
with them like that I've been very good
to them yeah but it is nice you can
definitely see there are lines where you
really definitely feel like you guys are
just playing yeah you're just playing
you're having you're having fun together
and then it's making it into the movie
and it's working yeah I mean that's we
rehearsed a lot with that to keep it
really keep it alive and then like I
said sometimes there's a scene in the
film where you know we're hidden down
behind something he's like I'm gonna
take a look okay and he looks knee pops
back down and what you see goes too fast
and that got in the movies just laughs
we have a clip here from Iron Man 3 I
believe this is where you're trying to
you you're in the midst of some action
when you get interrupted is that correct
I think that's exactly what is this the
porn scene or is this just is there a
porn scene they never show me the good
stuff I haven't seen I haven't seen the
movie yet so this may be this show hold
on oh won't air tonight you've seen to
that so I hope it's got pornography and
it
three
[Music]
hang on say hello river trick straddling
and you look up in summation going from
the inside out kind of a bright orange
yeah I've had that who is this it's me
pal now last time I went missing if I
remember correctly you came looking for
me what are you doing little knocking
top making friends at peg Sam what are
you doing your redesign your big rebrand
that was aim right yeah I'm gonna find a
heavy-duty ComStat right now I need your
login it's the same as it's always been
war machine 68 password please well look
I got to change it every time you've
hack in Tony it's not the 80s nobody
says anymore give me your login war
machine rocks with an axe all caps
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]